as you know i'm not the greatest with
words so
oh my gosh can we just pause for a
minute and talk about the words okay
l has called me bulky
um that was fun one day when you're like
you're just you're just really bulky and
i'm like and i meant like strong like it
was right
right and then another time we were
having delicious breakfast at this very
very fancy hotel restaurant in
california napa valley got brought up
the other day and you had your breakfast
and first you weren't sure what to do
with your eggs and we're like first i
don't eat breakfast that's why
but you didn't know what to put on your
eggs so we were like salt and pepper
and then you ate it and it was like wow
how was that kyle and you're like it was
it was the beef hash i think it was
called it was and you said it was too
flavorful
so
yeah kyle can you can be a little like
um what goes on in your head and what
comes out of your mouth aren't really
jiving
yeah i get i i blame my mom for that
she's she's worse than i am so really no
i think this oh yeah yeah if you would
oh my gosh yeah you need to spend some
time around my mom and you would
understand
why my brain and my mouth don't work
together that's why she's always just
video video videotaping
that's probably a reason why she's
always behind the camera
for sure
yeah okay so so so anyway those are some
examples of kyle being
you know i meant loki is a compliment i
think it i think you understood but
i have a feeling that in the comments
people will be like um bulky is if
you're a girl like i don't even know
would you want me to call you bulky
yeah but i know i'm not bulky so
i meant strong like you're i remember
where were we driving like charleston or
something and we
stopped like somewhere at a gas station
or something and i don't know why
i gave you that compliment what i
thought was a compliment but
over as a compliment yeah maybe we were
in charleston or something like that
yeah and that's probably why when we
drove home from charleston on that trip
of eating our way through through south
carolina
why we stopped remember we went into the
juicy friends after we went and we just
like tried to pile up on whatever they
had because you probably gave me like a
a
a complex then that i was bulky oh my
god i was thinner than i am now for sure
i'm like i wasn't bulky
i was i was i was um i meant it as a
compliment
muscular at worst
yeah i mean okay whatever let's move on
before before i put my foot in my mouth
again you had a super kick-ass season in
2021 i was so stoked to be there at the
end and
but i'm curious
to credit you for your uh
your strength and getting my my dinner
to what i wanted it the night before
oh yeah you're maybe without that meal i
wouldn't have i wouldn't want
yes we went to dinner and they didn't
have you wanted um
yeah yeah chicken parmesan and
they were out and i was like do you have
chicken and they're like yeah and then
they're like it's just not breaded i'm
like it's easy just dip it in egg put
the breading on it and then she went
back and made [ __ ] happen and you got
your chicken parm yeah cause me
non-confrontational kyle i'm like okay
it's fine i'll just order something else
and danica is like no he wants a chicken
farm he's gonna get a chicken parm it's
easy it was the night before the biggest
race of the year to win the championship
can we tell another story about danica
trying to get what she wanted done about
um fourth of july many years ago
when
your cat climbed up a tree because my
dog chased your cat
and i felt really bad about that and um
so you went down to go see if the local
uh fire department would be able to get
my house was like right across the
street from the fire station so it's
yeah
very close and they were all they said
they couldn't
and i was like oh
oh really
and then i went and you came with me and
you stood
way back and i tried to be nice at first
for like a minute for like a minute i
was nice and then they it was dark and i
was like i was hoping you could help me
my friends came and like cats stuck in
the tree and and they were getting ready
they were doing nothing there was like
four or five of them doing nothing and i
was like
you know i really would appreciate it
and they were just putting up the wall
they're like in the movies it makes it
seem like we're supposed to do this but
we don't and they'll just come down
eventually i'm like yeah when they're
dehydrated and die
and it's summer it's like july in north
carolina
and i mean i threw some serious shade
out there to get them to come i threw i
i threw out social media disgrace to
them i was like look if you guys don't
come
and they came i did not say a word i was
like oh my god if i could just if i
could just leave right now i would
because i felt so
embarrassed so bad for everybody i felt
bad for them i felt bad for the cat i
felt yeah
it was going to be better than that i'm
trying to do better i'm trying to let
things go more
i'm a little more zen than i used to i
was gonna say you're more zen like now
so
how like one of the things transitioning
from one year to the next is you never
really know how it's gonna go
right like you want to have the same
year again next year
if you do
i mean
i'd be freaking blown away because it
was just ridiculous
um for people who don't know i mean the
normal amount of races that the cup
champion wins in a year is probably what
four to six i was gonna say five to
seven maybe at the most you won twice is
twice as many on top of all the big dirt
wins so
having the same year again would be
would be amazing and kind of it would be
phenomenal so but the one thing that
happens is when we all get to daytona at
the beginning of the year you never
really know how it's going to go because
people work on their cars in the off
season rules packages change sometimes
engine packages there's all kinds of
things that can shift and you really
don't know what happens from that you
know november through february time with
other cars how it's going to go is kind
of a mystery so
what i mean i was never in the shop
enough to know
let's face it um it wasn't my fun zone
um
but what what happened like what can you
do what can you do as a team like what
do you know is happening
whose job is it to make sure the car is
to make sure it's really good the next
year this year is different than any
other year for me because
we're going from the gen 6 car which is
what i was always in even though it had
different rules packages yo between
gears and stuff but anyways we're going
from the gen 6 to the next gen car which
is totally different so
yeah like
i think you can't have any expectations
i don't like i i mean we we just won 10
11 races last year we could go win list
this year it's just how it goes with a
new car but
um
so i don't know i haven't had much
testing in it i was gone while they
tested in charlotte so i don't even know
like how they drive that much
so far it's looked like it's a bit of a
disaster
yeah
i mean
i think they've made improvements on it
um
but yes i think they've kind of ran
your times kind of ran out a little bit
to really
do r and d on what's the proper package
but as far as the off-season stuff yeah
i don't know like i think
i like i'm probably similar to you i
don't
i don't know anything about race car you
know more about a race car than i do so
i don't go in the shop at all and like
pick their brains out what they're
changing where their improvements are
that they've found and
what's the difference in the cars like i
can't even talk about what the
difference is um
i guess it's independence independent
suspension
the shifting is different stuff like
that what does that even mean so yeah i
don't know but uh
yeah um maybe people think it's funny
that we don't really know that stuff
drivers are really up on it some drivers
are into it they get it you know some of
them are really into the cars but i i
never i didn't even know where the sway
bar was and i don't know i've looked
under a stock car maybe twice in my
career but i mean it doesn't matter it
doesn't i mean my job's a drive and
there's the work on it and so yeah i
think you know cliff my crew chief cliff
daniels the engineers
the engineers and crew chiefs and other
teams
um really i think you have to lean on
everybody at your race shop to
prepare your cars especially when it's a
new generation car
um you gotta lean on chevrolet and even
other teams you know i think the other
chevy teams are really communicating
well right now from what i hear so
um that should hopefully
you know
give us an edge uh or get us closer to
where we need to be once the season
starts if you were to rank
driver car
engine crew chief pick like what
what rank does that stuff fall i don't
want to go simple car versus driver
because
i mean you can you can answer car versus
driver what's more important um
but i'm kind of curious of maybe a
little bit of a deeper sort of look into
what matters
in your opinion
yeah um yeah i mean i've only ever
thought about it as
car and driver but i think once you
start throwing in all those other things
um i think then it almost
it almost narrows it's where
everything's
closer to equal like everything matters
equally or close to equal um because
you could
view your pit crew like
in phoenix i don't win the championship
without my pit crew
um so everybody matters and every every
person every job in that shop matters um
you know the car matters the driver
driver matters picture matters i mean
heck the the business people upstairs
matter you know just as much as anybody
else does because your car's not funded
it's you're not gonna they're not gonna
have the resources to go fast so
it's really hard i feel like to
say one thing is more important than the
other or has a bigger factor than the
others i my car versus driver
car versus driver
um
i would have to give the edge to the car
for sure um i think
you can look at my career i i think
you know in 2017
i won four races um 2018 i won zero
races
2021 i won 11. so i you know just
i'm not i'm not i'm probably a better
driver than i was back then but not way
better um i just think you know now that
i'm at hendrick motorsports your their
equipment was and resources um you made
the car
better so yes
your car means a lot but you still also
have to have a really good driver i mean
there's nobody that lucks into a win uh
or or championship for that matter yeah
well if it's just simple if you just
take like a great driver and a bad car
versus a
great car and a bad driver like
i mean you know if you it you can't have
a harvard best driver
this last year in 2020 and won zero and
21 and he's
he's an amazing race car driver so yeah
you know somewhere
they were off in their on their race
cars
oh i remember i remember all your wins
in 2017 because we flew together to and
from all the races and that jet had to
wait for you and all your wins every
time and i was like
here we go again
i appreciate it oh man it's okay